about 90 million years ago
the frozen realm of Antarctica used to
be a lush swampy temperate forest
similar to those found in New Zealand
today the rainforest managed to thrive
even with four months of polar night
when there was no sunlight what if this
ancient rainforest decided it was time
to make a comeback
what if Antarctica became a rainforest
would this work out well for us
don't be devastated for the human race
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Antarctica and were a
rainforest rainforests are the oldest
living ecosystems on land and there is
complex as they are diverse they're home
to over half of the planets plant and
animal species while only covering six
percent of the Earth's surface just ten
square kilometres of rainforests can
contain up to 1,500 flowering plants 750
different species of trees 400 species
of birds and 150 species of butterflies
Antarctica has an area of 14 million
square kilometres which makes it about
1.4 times bigger than Europe and almost
twice the size of Australia now imagine
all that frozen tundra was lush with
plant and animal life
if Antarctica was a rainforest it could
consume more of the world's carbon
dioxide reducing the amount in the
atmosphere that could be very helpful in
our fight against climate change
there could be new resources for us to
exploit such as plants for medicines and
food more trees for buildings and fancy
furniture awesome right but there is a
downside before we would be able to
exploit these new resources we would
need to increase the carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere carbon dioxide helps to
heat the Earth's atmosphere the current
levels of atmospheric carbon dioxide
won't be able to support a massive
temperate rainforest in Antarctica but
as we know increasing carbon dioxide is
a bad idea it would be extremely harmful
and only add fuel to the fire that is
climate change and with Antarctica going
through its green makeover massive
amounts of ice would melt this means
that there would be less white area to
reflect sunlight and more dark area to
absorb warmth that would accelerate
climate change to the point that the
earth wouldn't even be hospitable for us
but with the carbon dioxide consumed by
the new rainforest balance out the
increased warming well here's the
problem we don't know current studies
haven't been able to come up with an
answer to this question so you feel
lucky well do you
the loss of ice would also impact the
species that currently inhabit that area
no not the Penguins and to make matters
worse ice doesn't just disappear
it melts all that water would have to go
somewhere the Antarctic and Southern
Ocean coalition estimates that sea
levels would rise at least 60 meters
Florida the Amazon River Basin and
central China they'd all be underwater
between 1 & 2 billion people would be
displaced that is unless they want to go
the way of Atlantis well can't get any
worse can it our ocean currents would be
disrupted by the influx of water so what
does all this mean for you well the
changing ocean currents could seriously
mess up the Earth's weather patterns
agricultural land that we depend on for
food could be turned into deserts
deserts could be turned into flooded
plains we can only guess where these
changes might occur because of how
complex the Earth's weather system is so
could Antarctica turn into a rainforest
well it's already starting to happen
climate change is currently turning
Antarctica green if we don't curb our
greenhouse gas emissions our planet is
going to continue to heat up and ice is
going to continue to melt it is possible
that eventually we could turn Antarctica
into a green continent but it may lead
to devastating consequences for our
survival and if Antarctica did become a
rainforest that would mean a lot of
uncharted territory to explore
the Amazon rainforest alone a new
species is discovered every other day
what could be hiding in a new Antarctic
rainforest could we finally find some
long-lost creatures like Bigfoot well
that's a story for another what is